you
95 was the number and MC ret is the one
who got it let me also ignore spectators
so we have Sicilian land and let's go
with the open Sicilian if I wanted to
still think about closed Sicilian I
would I would go with Knight c3 instead
of Knight f3 to reserve possibilities
for f4 alright so this is we're entering
a pretty critical line here very uh how
can we define e 5
well critical line because of the great
weaknesses that are left behind
d6 I could jump into d5 is the main one
where I have support and I think I'm
going to go right after just ninety six
and pick up the bishop pair I think
what's more I think what's more normal
is maybe the knight f6 move and that's
something I could reference after the
game but so I have I have the bishop
here now I'm going to try and keep black
from getting in d5 do I have something
better than avoiding the Queen exchange
I know I know that sounds really weird
because I'm a big fan of trading Queens
but I think I think it's I think it's
best to actually trade still with Jade
Queens and if I play Knight c3 to Emma I
have some concern about c2 I would
really like to play c3 to stop the
knight from causing any havoc or any to
any trouble
and is it is it worth that time my other
thought is Knight c3 to prevent this
advance or actually what about Bishop
here hmm I could do that Bishop c4 and
maybe I could just bump my king over I
don't know how much I would really have
to worry yeah let me come on play Bishop
c4 I don't want to play Knight c3 let me
let me do this oh you know it's gonna
happen it was gonna happen Bishop c4
Knight b4 and by the way my opponent
better not be listening right
this is muted isn't it I hope so okay so
Bishop c4 Knight B for threatening c2
and then d f-- d5 is prepped well okay
that's fine if you're gonna do that do
it if you're gonna do that do it how's
that for advice if you're gonna do that
do it great advice right there great
advice hmm I guess in a way d5 could
still be played even on this move and
that's interesting like cuz switch
switching that move order it's something
I've referenced before night before with
d5 or what about d5 and then and then
night before stuff maybe after an
exchange on this square so now I'm going
to make sure this Knight doesn't bother
me and I'm assuming that this move was
played to expand with b5 and then I
guess the bishops going to go to b7 and
let me back up this is a move I'm gonna
have to be aware of Knight a5 especially
with the Bishop on b7 the knight would
hit the bishop and then the bishop would
be hitting upon but I do have a
convenient reply of Bishop c2 I wonder
if I should keep my Bishop on this
diagonal so a4 comes to mind to me
Knight a5 with Bishop back but now this
this issue here let me let me develop I
guess uh when I play I guess this d5
could be played and I I just I can't
really stop it can I so you can't have
it all can you you can't still keep this
pawn backward and be playing with the
two pair so let me develop in this way
I'm doing this to reinforce this pond
I'm assuming d5 will be played my real
could come to life on the e-file and
also my knight cannot pivot on f1 which
is allowing me to complete development
I'm that's all I'm really looking to do
right now is finished my Queen side
development and let me want to get my
room night out to its most natural
square this rook is currently tied down
to the defense of the night if pawn push
to defend here this Knight is then in a
pin and I could look to pile up on it
although I guess this is a convenient
reply Knight a5 to take my bishop off of
this diagonal so f6 is maybe kind of
right you certainly have to be very
concerned about throwing one of your
pieces in it yeah voluntarily going into
a pin how else to defend this pawn
though is actually maybe a more
important question how else do you
defend it you can't come over this rook
is already tied down to the night if
Knight a5 I just snip I'll give up a pot
I'll give up my bishop pair if I could
get be getting a pond and I believe that
that is um that is the best move hmm
alright so rook here actually
my knight is all of a sudden is sort of
out of play isn't he it sure does seem
that way
I'm also down on time I'd really like my
knight on this square did I really never
consider Knight e4 to c5 shame on me
shame on me
can I really do that can I really switch
gears like this I think I could I think
I'm developed enough to maybe try to get
my knight on this square maybe somehow
supported with my bishop on e3 all right
let's go Knight c5 and then this is
going to be incredibly awkward for black
and I think that I can get that and in
fact if 95 I think I'm I'm okay with
giving up my Bishop Knight c5 Knight a5
Knight takes here and well I can't
tolerate this and that he's way too
tricky as many of you know and now this
I have the bishop hit and I'm looking at
a knight fork 132 to
two minutes Bishop back here I believe
is best but then there's a disconnect
between the rooks and I'll be looking
for a way to possibly exploit that but
you're not having that here's going to
be winning material and I'm only looking
right now looking for something that
might be better and there's not going to
be something better bishop CA and I
believe was the best move or rook over
here which seems awkward this is this is
winning material in fact Black has to
now walk into a discovered attack King
here yeah otherwise here you're lying up
with the bishop Knight takes here and
then just get all my pieces working and
I could even avoid the knight takes
Bishop move and we get on the seventh
rank
my only concern as far as King safety is
to do what I just need to make sure I
get castled okay with giving that up so
flight square wise I'll be looking to
play to a dark square with my King so
I'll look at the move f3 or h3 I might
want to might want to do it yeah I might
want to just do this one because it does
two things it's a it's a dark flight
square for my King and on top of it it
is blunting this bishops diagonal from
putting pressure on g2 at these at this
point these positional factors that I'm
referencing really aren't going to carry
has great await since the there's a
material deficit but nevertheless it is
still doing those two important things
so let me give check and now he's
falling King is quite limited going here
as a counter tech is available I'm gonna
take this actually now I'm gonna go here
I don't like my technique I don't want
to allow this rook activity I'm strictly
pawn grabbing at that point and maybe
I'd be a little bit safer if the King
ran over to h2 I'm really tempted to
just take this Knight
I mean they can give back material but
I'm not going to do that so I'm looking
at potentially before in some type of a
mating net against the black King I
don't have to play for some mate but it
seems like he's running short on squares
so it's a very real possibility so let
me just get rid of that Knight rook here
I play here stop any counter-attack
that's my um that's my main goal at this
point I don't want any complications and
rut material keep it really really
simple right here activity was just or
there was a coordination on e to you
know I was I was already on that fish up
earlier did I miss that we both missed
it I don't know how many moves I was
missed for though I just cut the King
off and then run for me no stalemates no
Stanley it's is the last thing all right
good game MC Rhett I believe this was
the first time that we played it's hard
to uh it's hard to keep track all right
but let's let's go back here and see if
either one of us can make improvements
here so this is a it's not as vesion
akov without Knight f6 I'm forgetting
the I'm forgetting the name right now
somebody help me out quickly in the chat
Kurt has something um it's gonna bother
me as soon as I see it but look let's
continue here right here is where I
think Knight f6 there's an improvement
yes thank you um hedgehogs for me in the
twitch chat kalashnikov I knew it I knew
I would know it when I what I saw it
typed out there but okay so from this
position this was my first thought when
you did play Bishop c5 I was thinking I
was used to seeing Knight f6 so I
immediately started to wonder what were
the differences between the two and as
it turns out your
with Knight f6 you're you're that much
faster with your development because
what was your bishops journey in this
game he went to c5 I played to d6 and he
went to d6 again he made two moves and
then I recaptured on d6 whereas I'm
going to go to d6 pretty much whether
you go here to c5 or to f6 if you play
Knight f6 I believe I still jump in
there you take I take and your one move
quicker you're a step ahead with your
own development so that's just a quick
way you could be saving time by not
playing here just just keep your Bishop
home and be prepared to capture the
knight in one move instead of two that's
that's a time-saver really quick you
should be able to get d5 and I think I
think you've well maybe it's not where I
mean you're you're able to get rid of
your backward pawn which is a good thing
a good positional correct iment or a
good way to correct your your pawn
structure Isis I should say but the
other thing is you know the time and I
do have the two bishops in this position
so if you don't have anything right away
this this is going to tell in almost all
variations having an open position I
have I would have the bishop pair defy
getting d5 in is a good idea because it
corrects your pawn structure makes your
gets rid of your liability but notice
the other thing it's doing its welcoming
exchanges which is beneficial to the
side who has that bishop pair so I think
it's already important to maybe not be
playing Bishop c5 at that early point
and instead Knight f6 and this move here
d6 is also another thought which is not
even allowing my knight to jump in there
but uh that's one way to save a move
Knight f6 you get b5 in I don't know how
well I played this to be perfectly
honest with the with the c3 move and I
guess I could on the other hand a way to
look at it is I could afford these
lower type of moves because I have this
long-term asset of the bishop pair so
you do well you get rid of your
liability and this this had to be a
pretty scary move to make but I believe
it was best f6 it's not a not a better
way to defend that pawn and I during the
game I was talking about
oh here yeah I could have
I played Knight f3 just throwing it to a
natural square hitting this pawn but
even Knight e4 to this square right away
I ended up backtracking so this is
something else that I should have been
considering Knight e4 to c5 these dark
Squaresoft points on the Queen side when
you when you're playing b5 I wasn't
really sending it to myself during the
game but as soon as you're doing b5
which should come to mind for me a bit
more
is this c5 square I don't necessarily
have to have a support point for it in
that of a pond or a bishop but when you
whenever you give up your dark square
Bishop and you're moving moving your
cons like this which isn't necessarily a
bad thing but I should be more focused
my thing is I should be a bit more
focused on the Queen side and these dark
square possibilities for this night in
particular in c5 and that's where I
ended up winning the material cap became
very difficult and it it had to have
been tough a tough decision all right
getting your King here seems natural
King here but maybe it's important to do
something different maybe there's a more
aggressive way to get out of this pin
this is what you can classify as a
strictly defensive move getting out of a
pin Knight to FA you get out of trouble
but what about something more aggressive
where you kick the bishop off of this
diagonal and you keep your king as is
King to f8 notice how it leaves him
vulnerable so eventually there might be
some bishop moves where you're then
having to react yet again King AJ is
something you don't really want to do
either because then you you still suffer
from the well yeah you still have to
cope with possibilities for back rank
mate
stuff so maybe maybe maybe night 285 at
this point Bishop c2 and kind of go from
there that would maybe be an improvement
yeah actually yeah how about that Knight
a5 Bishop c2 Knight f4 like you did in
the game and then I have to be concerned
about Knight takes pawn here as well as
your Knight jumping into this d3 square
yeah I think this would be a much better
continuation Knight a5 oh but you know I
was saying it turned the game Knight a5
I wasn't going to move my best shot I
was still going to go with the night
here with then jumping into c5 but again
maybe Knight f4 would be there what
ended up happening you move your king I
jumped in and then you played there and
I was there in time yeah that's the
thing that's the thing Knight a5 if I'm
moving the bishop then you could come to
f4 freely for just a one moment without
being able to be captured by my bishop
I'd probably be going with the Knight to
a5 here once my knight was on c5 it's
very easy to go wrong and it did go
wrong bishop c8 was necessary to save
material but I think you'd still be
experiencing some problems just looking
at it from a structural standpoint as
soon as this capture is made you have an
unhealthy majority of pawns on the Kings
side I have a perfectly healthy majority
which means I can a bit more easily
create a passed pawn three versus two
but never really got to that point I got
the material edge and it's just trying
to not complicate when there was that
material edge all right
good game MC Rhett Nicorette
you